The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
Just a few announcements before
we get into the lecture today.
So the structure for today--
our lecture, two hours'
work in your groups.
We have, unfortunately,
Elle, the grad student
who's working with
the heat wave, who
would be using the heat
wave game, is sick today.
So she won't be able to come in.
But I'm working on rescheduling
a time for her to come in.
What I'd love to do is if we can
get her a web link of the heat
wave game that she could
then give you feedback on,
that might be good for you all.
For the rest of the class,
we've got Pablo in today.
He talked to the
snap team already.
Is he going to talk
to you again today?
Or are you guys all on
the right page with him?
STUDENT: It'd be nice
to show him the game.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
Oh, you didn't show
him the game then?
OK, cool, cool.
What I'd like him
to do is take a look
at the forecast-based
future game
today if he can at 2 o'clock.
I'm going to just
show him a build, get
some feedback from him.
And then he'll take a
look at the snap game.
And then if he's got time,
the two cholera games.
He can take a look at those.
And again, if you
want to give him
web links to playable
versions of the games,
just send them to the
Video Game Bosses list.
And I'll forward along.
Other announcements--
I'm going to email this
to the announcements
list later today.
This Friday there is a free
conference workshop thing
going on at a hotel,
I think, in Boston.
But it's being run by
Epic Games, about Unreal.
So they're going to do a
bunch of different workshops
from about 2:00 to 5:00 and
end the day with a networking
party.
So if you're interested in
using the Unreal engine and all
the different new things
about that engine,
they'll be running that.
They're also going to be on
campus Tuesday at 5:00 PM,
so Tuesday, November 18.
That can be found at
the GameLab website.
And they'll be talking
about Blueprint, a way
to do scripting in Unreal that's
kind of similar to some things
I've seen for Unity, but
it's baked into Unreal.
And if you used previous
versions of Unreal,
I think it's related to Akismet,
if you used that tool before.
Otherwise, upcoming guests
we have at the class that are
different from the syllabus-- on
Monday we're going to have two
writers and talking with Drew,
doing a little panel and then
a Q&A with y'all talking about
different ways of looking
at writing for games that I
think would be very directly
related to at least two of
the games that I've seen.
Because yours was a very
dialogue-driven game, yeah?
And then the Animal Crossing
kind of game, I imagine,
would be really
useful for you all.
Probably useful for
the other two, as well,
but those are the ones
that first came to my mind
when I was scheduling that one.
And then on the 19th, we have
Blizzard coming in, right?
PROFESSOR 2: I
think that's right.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
So Wednesday night,
Blizzard's going to come in.
And it's teams from
Heroes of the Storm?
PROFESSOR 2: I think so.
But--
PROFESSOR 1: But yeah, we're
not quite sure exactly who's
going to be there for that.
But we talked to them.
And we requested either Heroes
of the Storm or Hearthstone.
So one of those
groups, we'll begin
to talk about their
production process.
And you can ask them
things about what
it's like to work at Blizzard.
That's everything I've got.
Yeah, so I'm going to bring
it over to-- you're wired?
Cool.
Great.
PROFESSOR 2: So when I went
over to GDC Next just last week,
I met Richard.
Actually, he's been
to all that before.
And he gave this
talk on game audio.
And then I remembered,
wait a minute,
there's a talk on game audio
that's coming up in class.
And I was just going to fake it.
And then I heard his
talk and realized maybe
he should be the one
talking to you, instead.
So I invited him
and Andy Forsberg,
who's his partner
at Hexany Audio.
Let's see.
You'll see the name
of the company come up
in the next slide.
And they do professional
sound design
and audio design and music.
That includes things
like sound effects,
as well as scoring and
also advising companies
on things like the technology
that they're using.
And he's going to
talk a little bit
about how to do good audio on a
budget, as well as just things
to think about in your audio
design of your own game.
So I'm going to
hand it over to you.
And thank you very much
for speaking today.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
Well, thanks so much.
Happy to be here.
Just curious-- so the class,
I'm wondering, what level is it?
Is it more
introductory, advanced?
What's the focus?
PROFESSOR 2: Intermediate.
So they're making video games.
But it's a class that
actually has prerequisites.
So they needed to take another
classes, either in game design
or in programming,
before they came here.
RICHARD LUDLOW: OK.
Cool, cool.
So I'm just curious-- show
of hands, how many people
are planning to go
out into the world
after you graduate and
become game designers,
game developers?
Anyone?
OK, cool, cool.
Nice.
That's cool.
ANDY FORSBERG: Sweet.
No, very nice.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Great.
So yeah, we're going to
talk to you about music
and sound in games and then give
a little bit of very practical
advice about working
with composers
and working with
sound designers.
And so that's the situation
most of you will probably be in.
So we'll give you a little
overview of ourselves
in a second.
But if you want to go
on to the next slide,
we're going to talk
about three key areas.
Yeah, we're just going
to tag team this.
So the three things
we're going to talk about
are, number one, Interactivity.
So we're going to
talk to you about what
makes game audio
different than film audio
and why you should
care about it.
And then in
Agreements, we're going
to talk about contracts and what
that looks like for you hiring
a composer or a sound designer,
which is really most often
the case with an indy game.
And then lastly, we'll talk
about money and budgets
and how much hiring one
of us audio guys takes.
So a little bit about us--
I'm Richard Ludlow, again.
And I'm the audio
director of our company.
And Andy is the music director.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah we both went
to school in Boston, actually.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah,
just across the river
over at Berkeley and did
their game audio thing.
And now we started the
company Hexany Audio.
And basically, music, sound,
and dialogue, as well as
implementation services are
what we do with our clients.
ANDY FORSBERG: And we're based
in Los Angeles, obviously.
RICHARD LUDLOW:
Yeah, based in LA.
And we have experience
working on larger AAA console
games, lots of mobile indie
things, so a really wide range.
And we do film and
commercial media, as well.
But our focus really is
on games and interactivity
and the technology
that drives that.
So yeah, without
further ado, if you want
to jump ahead to The Basics.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah, absolutely.
So music in games is all
about the dynamic experience
and player input in the game
and how the music and sound
effects adapt around that.
Obviously, it's much
different than linear media,
such as film, TV, et cetera.
When you watch a film,
that same explosion
is going to happen in the
same point every time.
So obviously, with games
we have to change that.
Because games are different.
We have to make it adaptive
to what's going on.
So there's four major parts
to audio in a game usually.
There's the music.
There's the sound
and the dialogue.
But the major part
of this, again,
is the implementation
into the game.
If we write amazing
music or sound effects
or we have the coolest
voiceover artists in the world
and we get them to do
that stuff for our game--
if we implement it incorrectly
or the developer doesn't
do such a great job
because there wasn't
a dialogue between
us, then all the stuff
on the left side,
those three things,
almost don't even matter.
So it's all about how
it gets put in the game,
as well as how it's crafted.
RICHARD LUDLOW: And
we're going to talk
about that in the
Interactivity section
if you're like, what
is this implementation
witchcraft we speak of?
ANDY FORSBERG: Exactly.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Anyway.
ANDY FORSBERG: Next slide?
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
So The Importance of
Audio-- really talking
about why you guys
should care about audio.
Because so often you think,
OK, I've got this mobile game.
I'm going to shut off the audio.
Who cares about it?
But the depth that it
adds is really important.
And we'd just like to touch
on three key areas of why
music and sound is so important
in games, if you want to--
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah.
The first thing, obviously,
the emotional factor.
And you can't get around that.
With everything else,
basically, audio
goes straight to the
center of your brain
that controls that stuff.
It just skips everything
else and stimulates that.
So obviously, when
we were kids we
turned the music off of a
game or turned the music off
of a film, and we'd
realize that we
weren't having those
emotional responses that we
did when it was on.
So obviously, emotion is
a huge part of what we do.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
And that's a chemical response.
Like Andy said, it's
actually eliciting-- just
emphasize again-- a
chemical response.
Visuals do not trigger these
emotional processing centers.
It's sound and music.
That's stimulating parts of
your brain that are different
and actually
creating the emotion.
It's pretty amazing.
At least we like to think
so. [LAUGHS] Anyway, cool.
So the next one is Function.
And this isn't a great term.
But audio, it
supports the ability
for the player to really absorb
a lot of the game information.
So when I say "function,"
it has the function
of giving you
information and also
the function of telling
you what's going on
with regards to your action.
So for example, you're
walking down a hallway.
And there's a guy up ahead
that you hear maybe walking.
And you know, OK,
there's a guard up ahead.
And then maybe your oxygen
tank is running low.
And you've got a little "beep."
And your health is maybe at 50%.
Maybe there's an alarm
going off in the building.
You hear a guy in the next room.
You hear all these
different things.
And all of that is information
that's being processed and sent
to you.
And you're able to
absorb it all instantly
without needing to think and see
text on the screen that says,
oh, OK, I'm at 50% oxygen.
There's three enemies nearby.
It's getting dark out
because I hear the crickets.
This is just stuff that your
brain subconsciously absorbs.
So it's functional
in that it provides
that information for players in
an entirely new dimension that
is subconscious to them.
So you can convey lots of
subconscious information.
ANDY FORSBERG: Exactly.
RICHARD LUDLOW:
And then also, it's
that feel-good factor for games.
So you punch a guy.
Oh, well, hold up on that maybe.
But yeah, you punch a guy.
And it feels good in the game.
And that is because of that
trigger, the sound meshing
with the psychological.
Anyway, so the sounds
we were talking
about that are memorable--
I know you just played,
what was that, the Zelda
sound or something?
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah.
RICHARD LUDLOW: I
couldn't quite hear.
ANDY FORSBERG:
Yeah, it obviously
has to be memorable with
game audio, as well.
And yeah, you played
the Zelda one.
Think of the countdown
for Mario Kart
where it makes you want to hit
A really fast and get everyone,
obviously-- but there's
countless examples.
We might have--
[VIDEO GAME SOUND]
RICHARD LUDLOW: You
could just play them all.
Just play them all.
ANDY FORSBERG: Let's see.
RICHARD LUDLOW: I'm not
sure if you've played them.
But I'll just talk about--
[COUNTDOWN SOUNDS]
So these are really
iconic sounds.
And I think the Mario
coin sound is next.
Let's see.
[COIN SOUND]
So that sound has been in an
entire generation of games.
And the Zelda sound,
when you hear that,
that's extremely
rewarding for the player.
It's extremely memorable.
Sound is burned into
a player's conscience
in a way that
doesn't necessarily
happen with visuals.
You hear that. [SNAPS] And then
you hear the achievement sound
that we played.
And it's like, oh,
I've unlocked that.
There's this stimulating
reward response.
And so good sound and
bad sound is going
to stick with your players.
And it can really
help set that game
apart so that later
on the players
are remembering your game
in a very unique way.
Anyway--
ANDY FORSBERG: Next slide.
RICHARD LUDLOW: We'll move
on to the real stuff now.
So Interactivity.
That was kind of the preface.
So the first section
that we talk about
is it that implementation
and how that works in games.
And that interactivity
is a huge part of that.
So if you want to jump
ahead to the next slide--
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah.
So on the music side of things,
obviously, if you want music
that changes dynamically based
on what the player is doing,
whether he's
walking into a field
and staying there for five
hours because he left it on
to go make a sandwich or
because he's walking in to buy
something from a shopkeeper.
So how do we do that?
There are several
different things
we can do, whether a player's
going into battle, et cetera.
We can use one system called
layering, which Richard's going
to talk about in another slide.
We're going to talk
about crossfading.
And then we're going to give
you an example of branching,
as well.
And then there's
also generative.
And these are just a few.
There are so many options that
we can use to implement music
in a cool, interactive way.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
So let's jump over to
one of the examples.
And go ahead and throw that up.
Don't hit the Play
button quite yet.
So you can hit the next slide.
And it'll pop up the graph.
All right.
So what you're seeing here is
the idea of a layered score.
So in this one, this is a piece
of music I wrote for a game
where there's three
different intensity layers.
And you're going to hear a first
one that's very low intensity.
And then you're going to hear
these other layers come in
on top as maybe the
player starts to go
into an area with enemies.
And then they go into an
area where they're in battle.
And you'll hear the music
stack in a very dynamic way.
Anyway, go ahead and hit play.
Let's see.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So that low intensity.
Players done some [INAUDIBLE].
The second layer's
going to come in on top.
[MUSIC INTENSIFIES]
You hear all three
layers, though, I think.
Back to just the first two.
And then just the first one.
So you can see this as well.
You could hear the layers fading
out in and between one another.
But it was a very
dynamic experience.
So this is where
we'd take the music,
and we'd specifically
craft it and write it
so that these things could stack
and be triggered dynamically
based on whatever
the player is doing.
So let's jump ahead
to the next slide.
So this is one more
example-- and this
is the last one we'll
show you for music--
that deals with the way that
music can move dynamically
between states again.
So yeah, so we've got
the low, medium, high.
But this time,
we've broken it out
into smaller, little chunks.
So the player will do something.
And the musical will actually
wait until the musical point,
like the next bar or beat.
And then it will begin
a transitional segment
into the next level intensities.
And this is going to be a
much more dynamic and fluid
experience than the layering.
So go ahead and hit Play.
[AMBIENT MUSIC]
Low intensity, again.
So a player's going
to do something.
And it's going to come
in with the transition.
[MUSIC INTENSIFIES]
Transition.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now we're going
to go into medium.
We're in medium.
The player's going
to do something.
And the music's going to
wait to do the transition.
Transition.
[MUSIC CHANGES]
Now it's running the high.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The music's going to wait and
then go into the transition.
And back to low.
Cool.
So you saw the music move
through-- one, two, three,
four-- six different
pieces there.
But it sounded like the
experience was being scored.
So again, the idea here is
we're trying to-- again,
with the film, you watch it.
It goes by.
You know what's going to happen.
We don't know what's going
to happen with the game.
So we write music that
can change and adapt
like that, in a
very film-like way
to score the player experience.
So why do we do this?
ANDY FORSBERG: So obviously,
it creates a more immersive
and dynamic player experience.
Any time we are
taking you guys out
of that escapist experience,
we're not doing our job.
It extends track
longevity, which
we'll explain later with budgets
why that's nice, as well.
But you get better
replay value out of it.
And it's the greatest value
from each individual minute
of music.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah, instead
of having to hire someone
to write three different
pieces of music,
if you're on a
budget, you can say,
we'll do one piece of music.
And we'll make it layered.
And it'll be one
better piece of music.
ANDY FORSBERG: Exactly.
Because if a movie
is 90 minutes long
and they want 60
minutes of music,
you write 60 minutes of music.
One small mobile game could
have 15 minutes of music.
Or it could have one minute
of music or three minutes.
So it all depends.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
And that goes into-- we'll
talk about with budgets
how that affects that.
But so yeah, jumping
onto the next slide,
how do we do these
interactive systems?
We build them with what
we call audio middleware.
And two of the commercial ones
are FMOD, that you see here.
And if you want to jump ahead
to the next one-- Wwise.
And these are just screenshots.
And essentially, these allow us
to interface with programmers
and set up these musical
triggers and these points
of musical change based
on different parameters,
like number of enemies around
or game state or health,
and let us set up these
musical transitions
and things like that.
So yeah, we can jump
onto the next section.
Agreements.
So you've learned all
about interactivity.
And you're like,
yes, this is awesome.
I'm going to hire
a game composer
so that they can do this stuff.
And then with
music, though, it's
obviously a creative
piece of content.
So the agreements look
a little different
sometimes than other agreements.
And so we're going to show
you three different kinds.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah.
So the purposes
of these contracts
are, obviously, to see
who owns it, obviously,
first and foremost.
What we're going to
be delivering to you.
What the delivery milestones
are in a game just as
there's development milestones.
How much you guys
are paying, which
is super important
for you and us.
And what's your
rights as a developer?
Where can you use it?
Can you go around and
license it to use it
in all the things involved
with your project or no?
And what are our usage rights?
Can we use it in our portfolio,
on our Facebook page?
Can we do that sort of thing?
So we're just going to go
through a few of the contract
types here.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
And it's really important to
spell out all those things.
So yeah, let's look
at the first one.
Work for Hire.
This is the most common
type of agreement
that you run into
with composers.
And it's essentially
where I'm the composer,
I've written music, and I am
selling you my music or sound.
You're buying it from me.
And you're taking all the
rights for it as a developer.
You become the owners
of the music and sound.
And so you've got the
rights associated with it.
And because you have the
rights, the developer then
can usually use
the audio however
they want in the project.
Because you own it.
You've also got the exclusive
right to use the audio,
meaning you're the only
ones that can use it.
I can't go around and
turn around and sell it
to Bob or Joe over there.
You've bought it.
It's yours.
And then lastly-- this
is the disadvantage
for developers-- is that this
is a more expensive agreement.
Because you are buying
out all of our rights.
And I'm going to show in
detail in a few slides
some important clauses to be
aware of in these contracts.
But yeah, so let's talk about on
the other end of the spectrum.
We've got work for hire, where
you and me-- the composer
selling the developer my rights.
And then on the other end of the
spectrum, we've got licenses.
ANDY FORSBERG: Right.
So we have two
sorts of licenses.
The first we'll talk about
is the non-exclusive.
So this means that
we are retaining
the rights of the music,
sound effects, anything
we do for your project.
We could go around and turn
it to another game, et cetera.
However, don't be
afraid of these.
We're writing the
same custom music
for your game, which is
super important to remember.
You're getting the
same exact product.
It's obviously a lot cheaper.
And it's a great way to save
yourself some money when
working with people like us.
And again, you can
still have unrestricted
use of the audio in your
project and things involved
with that usually.
But again, we could turn around
and use this for whatever we
would like to use it for.
So yeah, those are
the main reasons--
RICHARD LUDLOW: And we use this
negotiating with developers
all the time.
So if they don't want to
buy out all of our rights
and pay that full price,
we'll say, OK, well,
we'll retain the right to
go sell it to Bob and Joe
and still give you
the same music.
ANDY FORSBERG: And then
we have, obviously,
the exclusive license,
which is you're going
to retain all of the rights.
But it's usually for a
certain amount of time.
And then those rights
transfer back to us.
And sometimes it's
industry-specific.
So we might be able to use that
audio in a trailer or a film
or something.
However, pertaining to the game
or anything in the game world,
we're not going to turn
around and license that
to someone else.
Usually this lasts
about one to five years.
We like to call this
the happy medium
between the work for hire and
the non-exclusive license.
And it really is a healthy
balance of price and control.
Because it's right in the middle
as far as price is concerned.
And everyone's happy.
You guys could use
it for what you need.
But then we also get those
rights back. eventually.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
So work for hire--
I make the music.
I'm the composer.
I sell it to you.
You get all the rights.
Non-exclusive--
I'm the composer.
I make the music.
I retain all the rights.
And I can sell it
to other people.
With exclusive,
I'm the composer.
I make the music.
I retain the rights.
But I give you the
exclusive right to it.
So I can't sell
it to anyone else.
And then it usually
reverts back to us
after a brief
time, as discussed.
So most common, though,
is the work for hire.
And you're seeing that contract,
and you're like, oh my god.
This is awful.
I don't want to see this.
But anyway, let's jump
through that really quick
and just a few key points
that really go to developers
helping protect themselves.
And I've got to hit Play
over here on my key notes
so that I can see all the
different slide changes.
One second.
OK, cool.
So the first thing is services.
It's like, what are you paying
for music, sound, dialogue?
What are you buying?
This will be really quick.
Jumping onto the next one,
so payment for services--
what are you getting paid?
You want to spell out exactly
how much you're going to charge
and how much you're going to
pay for the music and sound.
Next point, and this is the
independent contractor point.
That's important for
you as a developer.
Because this essentially says
that the composer or sound
designer you're hiring
is not on salary
and does not need benefits.
They have to take care
of their own taxes.
It just protects the developers.
So they make
everything clear there.
Next, warranties.
These are things, again, that
protect you, as the developer.
So this says, OK, the music
we're writing, its original.
We're not stealing John
Williams' music, as I always
say.
ANDY FORSBERG:
[HUMMING] score game.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yes,
right. [CHUCKLES]
But then if we do steal it--
and we're not going to steal it.
And there are some other
warranties, as well.
But we'll jump onto
the indemnification.
So then it usually says, if we
do steal John Williams' music,
you guys are protected.
And there's different
levels of indemnification.
But the indemnification
just says
it falls on us if
we screw things up.
Next, there's usually a little
confidential information
clause, a little NDA clause
about not disclosing things
and then some specific legal
language about the ownership
and assignment of rights
specific to work-for-hire,
legal mumbo-jumbo.
We'll skip the subcontract.
And then there are some rights
that are specific to us,
as the content creators.
So if you remember, we talked
about composer-specific rights,
things like the ability
for us to post our work
on our website, something
that we like in our contract
so that we can advertise music
to other people [INAUDIBLE]
them to hire us.
Similarly, we often spell out
how we're going to be credited.
And the credit is a
great way, as well,
to negotiate with your composer.
If you're on a budget,
maybe you say, OK, I'll
put your name at the
opening cinematic
instead of just in the
back to help compensate
for our lack of budget,
get you a little more
exposure, things like that.
So you spell out how
you want to be credited.
That's really it
for the contract.
I don't want to go
too detailed there.
But some key points
to be thinking about
if you guys ever hire a
composer or a sound designer.
Let's talk about money.
This is the question
most people have.
And whenever I meet a
developer, without fail,
within like 10 minutes of the
conversation, they're like,
ah, what do you charge?
ANDY FORSBERG: What's generally
what you charge for any game?
RICHARD LUDLOW: It's funny.
And I gave this
talk at GDC Next.
And you'll see by
the end of it why
I'm like, that's not a
question I can just answer.
And then I got like
three emails from people
who attended the talk
after and who were like,
can you just give me a
range for an indie budget?
Anyway, but you'll see why
that's funny in a minute.
Because my response is
always to them when they ask,
how much do you charge?
My response is always,
what's your budget?
And the reason being
because are so many factors,
like what the deadline
is, musical style,
whether or not we're talking
about a solo piano piece
versus epic orchestral piece.
ANDY FORSBERG: Are we
going to get live players
to play those orchestral
pieces or a piano player
to play that song, maybe.
RICHARD LUDLOW: You can
throw out the bullet points
if you want, just FYI.
We're just going through them.
Anyway, and what's
the release platform?
Is this the AAA console?
Or is it a Facebook game for
the American Cancer Society?
ANDY FORSBERG:
Again, are we going
to use a work-for-hire or
what one of the license deals?
RICHARD LUDLOW: Right.
Like we just talked about,
buying out the rights or us
keeping the rights?
Really big effect
on the price there.
How much are you buying?
We're like Costco.
[INAUDIBLE]
ANDY FORSBERG: But if you're
going to buy 100 sound effects,
that's obviously going to
be different than if you
need five sound effects
or 50 sound effects.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah, we give
bulk discounts all the time.
ANDY FORSBERG: Exactly.
And that goes into,
obviously, the depth
of the audio
experience, as well,
which is how crazy we're going
to get with interactivity,
if we're going to
be using middleware.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Like Andy
said with the mobile game,
you could put one minute,
three minutes, 10 minutes, 20
minutes, all in the same game.
It's going to be a better
game if you've got-- maybe
you don't need 20.
But if you've got more
than one looping track,
it's going to be a better game.
But the game still exists
with a single piece of music.
So saying, how
much do you charge,
is a very, very
difficult question
to answer without knowing--
ANDY FORSBERG: Any stipulations.
RICHARD LUDLOW: --more
about your game.
Yeah.
ANDY FORSBERG:
One of our clients
that we work with, on their page
where you go to contact them,
it says, when do you need
your project done by?
And one of the
options is, Yesterday.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
And deadlines are a
huge part of that.
Sometimes we get
calls where it's
like, we need this in
two days or in a day.
And we'll do it.
But it's going to cost more
than if you need it in a year.
So contacting, guys,
early is important.
Anyway, let's jump
on to payment models.
ANDY FORSBERG: And you can hit
all these bullet points again.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah,
I mean, we were just
basically talking about
how composers and sound
designers charge.
Typically with music, it's
a per-minute music, so not
per minute that we're working.
ANDY FORSBERG: And
then sound effects--
yeah, that we're working-- and
then sound effects are usually
per-asset.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Or
sometimes a flat fee.
That's also common
[INAUDIBLE] quote a project
and say, OK, I'll do
your whole project
regardless of how many sound
effects for, you know, $20,000.
I don't know, whatever.
ANDY FORSBERG:
Sometimes hourly rate.
We usually don't do this.
This is a really
hard one to engage.
RICHARD LUDLOW:
It's a valid thing.
People do it.
We don't.
ANDY FORSBERG: We don't.
RICHARD LUDLOW: But yeah.
[KNOCKING SOUNDS]
There's some weird thing
happening below us.
ANDY FORSBERG: Sorry.
And then usually, we really like
to get back-end profit sharing.
RICHARD LUDLOW: If the
budget isn't there.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah, that's
a big thing with audio
to think about.
At the end of the
day, is it really
going to cost you that much to
give 0.5% of back-end when you
can't give anything up front?
Because we always
have passion projects.
We make money on
some of our projects.
But we really like to believe
in games that are really cool.
And sometimes the best to do
that is just to share the game.
RICHARD LUDLOW: The
indie scene, they often
can't afford because they
don't have that upfront money.
And so we'll talk about
a back-end profit sharing
percentage.
And if you talk to people who
have been doing this 30 years,
that didn't exist
10, 20, 30 years ago.
Audio guys did not get back-end
profit sharing usually.
Because they were
just paid upfront.
But that's kind of gone away.
I guess that is probably
true of all industries.
But so thinking about that
is a very valid thing.
And it's usually accompanied
by some upfront fee.
It's usually a reduced amount.
But the back-end thing
is definitely valid.
We want new developers
to be less afraid of that
and more open to it.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah, absolutely.
RICHARD LUDLOW: And then any
combination of the above, too.
Cool.
Anyway, so how does
this break down?
And you can throw
all these up here.
Just showing you music,
sound, and dialogue.
There's a lot of
components here.
So when we're talking
about what we're charging,
we charge different prices
for themes in the music.
So if I write a musical
theme that has its setting,
and we charge one
price for that.
But then we might
put an arrangement
of that in an underwater level,
a desert level, a jungle level.
The same theme, but
different arrangements
for different levels.
And we charge less for
those arrangements.
Those little
transitional segments
you've heard in that demo I
played, those are transitions.
We charge less for those.
And any different price
for things like stingers,
like a coin pick-up
or an end game,
like, [HUMMING] sound
like that when you die.
With sound effects, we break
things out into primary sound
effects, like if you've got
a creature having an attack
sound, "ch."
And then it's like a
die sound, idle sound,
those are all primary sounds.
Iterations might be like,
attack01, attack02, attack03,
die01, die02.
And we charge less
for iterations.
UI and ambiences,
different prices there.
And then dialogue, there's just
a whole slew of components,
like casting.
Usually you have to hire
someone to cast all the actors.
ANDY FORSBERG:
Getting Kevin Spacey
for the next Call of Duty game.
Or where--
RICHARD LUDLOW: Kevin
Spacey for the next--
ANDY FORSBERG: --we're
doing it ourselves.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Who doesn't
want to use Kevin Spacey?
You're right.
And then so they
charge a few hundred,
a few thousand an hour,
depending on the actor.
Usually there's
someone directing them
while they're being recorded.
Someone's recording them,
editing them, processing.
Just throwing this
up here so you
know all the different
components of music-sound
that are out there.
So again, asking,
what do you charge,
what does your game
need, is a very--
we need to know what your
game needs before we can say.
ANDY FORSBERG: Cool, next slide.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
So we're getting
close to the end here.
Then we can do some questions.
But just talking about
a theoretical project--
say you've got a low budget,
$160,000 Kickstarter project.
So talking about
music-sound, we're
typically looking
at like 5% to 15%
of budget being
allocated to audio.
5% to 15%, usually
hovering around 10, 15, 20,
25-- very good.
ANDY FORSBERG: 100! [LAUGHS]
RICHARD LUDLOW:
No, but seriously.
And so a common
problem with this,
though, is that your game, to be
awesome, needs this much music.
But your budget is only going
to allow for this much music.
So let's say we've got
a hypothetical game here
where a project might need
18 minutes of music and 300
sound effects.
So say we were going to
charge like $750 a minute
for themes and $500 a
minute for arrangements,
which are kind of indie prices.
We charge up to-- we have
a different scale because
of all the different
factors involved--
but up to like $1,000 a
minute is pretty typical.
The big guys on AAA's will
be charging $2,500 a minute.
But up to $1,000
a minute of music
is pretty typical,
between $500 and $1,000.
And then maybe sound effects.
Maybe you use a combination
of all those, total $12,500.
Let's say this game,
to be awesome, again,
needs $23,500 for the audio.
And you're like, oh my
god, that's a lot of money.
And let's say the
developer has only
allocated $11,000 to audio.
ANDY FORSBERG: Right.
So some things we can do to
reduce the costs are-- we
can reduce the
original music themes
and increase the arrangements.
So we can just do
a lot of iterations
with things, which is actually
a very feasible option,
because those composers
were trained to do that.
We can reduce the number of
sound effects iterations,
just have more of
those primaries.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Only attack01
instead of 02, 03, 04.
ANDY FORSBERG: Exactly.
We can do back-end
profit sharing,
as we mentioned before.
So maybe at 3% on that.
And then we can use
a license agreement
instead of saying you're
using the work-for-hire.
RICHARD LUDLOW: So just some
common things to think about
in that negotiating
process about,
how can we work
with the audio guy
to reduce the cost to something
we're both comfortable with?
Yeah, so let's just
wrap up really quick.
What did we talk about?
Interactivity.
It's music.
It's sound.
It's responding dynamically
to player input.
The player does something.
The music, the sound,
it changes, it reacts.
It's going to create a
deeper player experience.
It's going to reduce the
cost if you do it right.
And we're doing this
with FMOD, Wwise, Fabric,
different audio middleware.
ANDY FORSBERG: And
then for budgets, we're
trying to look at 5% to 15% of
the total budget of your game
allocated to audio.
Remember to consider
back-end payments.
We really think
that's going to be
part of the future of how
audio works within, especially,
the indie market.
And just be willing to
negotiate and figure things out.
Your costs fluctuate.
Our costs fluctuate.
So it just needs to
be a negotiation.
We can usually
figure something out.
Any audio person can.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
Oh, and then we jumped
over Agreements.
ANDY FORSBERG: Oh, sorry.
I went right and down.
RICHARD LUDLOW: No,
it's cool It's all good.
And then, agreements,
again, we're
talking about work-for-hire.
I'm the composer.
I'm writing the music.
You, as the developer,
are buying it.
Licenses-- I'm the composer.
I write the music.
I obtain the rights.
And then I give you some type
of license to use the music.
But that wraps up, I
think, the four points
we were going to talk about.
If you guys have
specific questions,
we're happy to answer them.
Or Phil, if you have
any additional points
you want to touch on.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY FORSBERG: Thanks
RICHARD LUDLOW: Thanks.
PROFESSOR 2: I
think for questions,
if anyone has any
questions, I'll
repeat it since I'm a little
bit closer to the mic.
Although, maybe the
mic might pick you up
if you're in the
back of the room.
We'll give it a shot.
RICHARD LUDLOW: It doesn't need
to be a question about what
we talked about, too.
Any audio related things.
ANDY FORSBERG: Favorite color.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah,
as loud as you can.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 2: Did
you [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD LUDLOW: I think so.
So was the gist of
it basically being
folks using music and sound and
then getting takedown notices?
Is that what she said?
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah,
takedown notices
on some of those by
YouTube or Twitch.
RICHARD LUDLOW:
Yeah, absolutely.
So the whole
takedown notice thing
has really come about because
people are just using the music
or just using the sound without
asking for permission for it.
Now, in an actual
gameplay video,
if you're streaming
Twitch, that is really
a very developer-specific
question.
And that's not something that
we, as the composers and sound
designers, really even
have control over.
If it's for a game
and if it's in a game,
if we're working on a Nintendo
game and it goes out to them,
then that is owned by Nintendo.
And if it's not
owned by Nintendo,
they've got the license for it.
So it's all on them
with regards to that.
So some developers are
totally cool letting it slide.
Some developers are not.
But it's a shifting-- it's all
being figured out right now.
ANDY FORSBERG: And usually
that happens, obviously,
in the bigger game world.
The biggest game
that would probably
happen with in the
indie world would
be something like Journey,
or something like that.
RICHARD LUDLOW: And most
often, at least now, developers
are pretty cool with it.
But I know it's all being
figured out right now.
That's a very
shifting landscape.
ANDY FORSBERG: And it has to do
with royalties in music and--
RICHARD LUDLOW:
That's another thing.
ANDY FORSBERG: Collections have
been set up for film and TV
for eons now.
And there's a system
in place for that.
But there's really no
landscape for games yet.
RICHARD LUDLOW: It's a little
different with YouTube,
and the Twitch, as well.
We get paid 0.0001 cents
every time someone will
watch something on YouTube.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah,
it's insulting.
RICHARD LUDLOW: In
five years, hopefully,
that will all be figured out.
But sorry I don't
have a better answer.
our fault. It's the developer.
PROFESSOR 2: Just a
follow up question
on that-- it seems like in
order for all these services
to actually detect that
they're using the music,
they need to cross check
it against some sort
of audio database.
So is that something that
you, as composers, usually
end up submitting?
Or is that something that
the game companies usually
end up doing?
Or does it really depend
on the license agreement
that you have with the company?
ANDY FORSBERG: It's
usually the developer.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
So there's a couple
different ways.
We have friends who
work for PlayStation.
And they were just
talking about how
they posted things on their
PlayStation North America
account.
And they got taken down by
PlayStation Japan or something.
So their own companies
aren't even really
able to quite mesh
this together yet.
But the databases are sometimes
internal to publishers.
But also sometimes
they're scanning surfaces
that these royalties
agencies like BMI and ASCAP
actually have.
And they've got these automatic
scannings that are set up.
And that sometimes comes about
because we submit our music
to these royalty agencies
like ASCAP and BMI
in order to be able to get paid.
But then they use them to
find out how many times things
are getting played.
They don't use them to figure
out what should be taken down.
ANDY FORSBERG: Exactly.
Yeah, I think, especially
on the indie level,
the only way we would be
able to detect something
is if we went and
watched a YouTube video,
our music was in it, and
we're like, oh, crap!
That's our music.
RICHARD LUDLOW: We don't
have these engines going.
The publishers have teams
of people doing takedowns
on their content.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yay, team.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah, and I
don't know all the details
behind that.
ANDY FORSBERG: Sorry?
RICHARD LUDLOW: The
ASCAP stands for--
BOTH: American Society of
Composers and Publishers?
RICHARD LUDLOW: I want
to say Publishers.
I think they probably should.
I don't know, man.
We just get the
checks from them.
ANDY FORSBERG: BMI is
Broadcast Music, Incorporated.
PROFESSOR 2: So I can
take a look at that.
ANDY FORSBERG:
They're called PRO's.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Composers,
Authors, and Publishers.
PROFESSOR 2: Next one?
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yes.
PROFESSOR 2: Other questions?
Yeah, Liz?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
art talk of last class,
they have done an artist test
to see if the particular artists
are right for the game.
Is there an
equivalent for music?
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah, absolutely.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah, we
do those all the time.
And that's a totally legitimate
thing if you aren't sure.
Asking them to do
a 30-second demo.
I'd say a 30-second demo
is totally legitimate.
Yeah, and usually the best way
to do that, guys, just so you
know, take some gameplay,
be it from your game,
a different game, concept
art for your game,
take some visuals as a
video, send it to them.
Or just concept art,
send it to them.
And let them work with that.
ANDY FORSBERG:
Because we could even
do an interactive demo
for it at that point.
The big thing, again, is
there's the difference
between being able
to write good music
and having a core concept
for a game from the beginning
and thinking about interactivity
when you're composing and doing
sound effects.
Because it's a whole
different animal.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yeah.
But the demos are
totally legitimate.
We do them all the time.
But sending some
visuals along is
very important to making
sure you get what you want.
And then we're able to
see what the game is
going to look like and
then make that decision.
Otherwise, we might
write something
that you might not have
the vision for because we
haven't seen the art.
And maybe we could easily
do what you wanted,
but we just misinterpreted it
and went a different direction.
But yeah, tests are
legitimate, absolutely.
PROFESSOR 2: Questions?
AUDIENCE: How much are they
paid for the music test?
PROFESSOR 2: Will you be
paid for an audio test?
RICHARD LUDLOW: What
did the art guy say?
I'm curious.
AUDIENCE: They said [INAUDIBLE].
ANDY FORSBERG: We have not
found that to be extremely
common with what we do.
We'd like it to be more common.
RICHARD LUDLOW: It
used to be a thing.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah, it
used to be a huge thing.
RICHARD LUDLOW: For
commercials, it was a big thing.
You'd get paid for doing a demo.
ANDY FORSBERG: I
think it's definitely
more common in the game world.
In the film and TV
world, it's so saturated
with composers and
sound designers
right now that
they don't need to.
Because so many
people want the work.
But it is a respectful
thing to do,
I think if it's a longer demo.
If it's a shorter
demo, then it's like,
we're happy to get the gig.
RICHARD LUDLOW: We're going
to keep the rights to that,
anyway.
So you could say a couple
hundred bucks maybe.
But it's not a required thing.
If we want the gig, we're
happy to do a 30-second demo
to try and get it often.
It's nice to throw a
couple hundred bucks.
But at that point, it's
a couple hundred bucks.
It's not like-- it's pennies
in the grand scheme of things
if the project is larger.
So yeah, anyway,
hopefully that solves it.
PROFESSOR 2: Yes.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Any more?
AUDIENCE: Do you find
that part of your job
is convincing people
that audio is important?
ANDY FORSBERG: Oh yeah.
RICHARD LUDLOW: That's
a big part of it.
We use the three things--
emotion, function-- no.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah, I think
the biggest argument in that
is probably a mobile scene.
Like in class,
someone was probably
playing a mobile game during
our talk today and-- (LAUGHING)
just kidding.
But it's a big thing, is like
well, do they just mute that?
And then it's like,
yeah, you could say that.
But some people do listen to it.
When they do listen to it,
they listen on headphones.
And we were at a talk at
a conference this year
called GameSoundCon
with a composer
named Guy Whitmore, who did the
music for Peggle and Peggle 2.
And he was talking
about, there's
not a more intimate experience
for audio than in headphones
or in that arena.
But I think in general, it
is undeniably important.
RICHARD LUDLOW: You
can put out a game.
A mobile game can do
OK with bad audio.
We're not going to lie.
That's a thing,
like Flappy Bird.
Believe me, I love Flappy Bird.
I have triple-digits
score on Flappy Bird.
But if you want to
set your game apart,
people look at that
polished experience.
If we're talking
about indie games,
they look at
something like Journey
or mobile games, something like
Peggel 2, they look at that,
and they're like, wow,
this entire experience
is super polished.
ANDY FORSBERG:
It's a great game.
RICHARD LUDLOW: And it's broken
down into the three parts,
really.
It's the functional, it's
the mechanic of the game,
it's the visual,
and it's the audio.
And those are all a
third of the game.
And if you take out one of
those, you can sell the game.
If you don't have
great art, that's fine.
There's a lot of great games
that don't have great art.
If you don't have
great mechanics,
OK, maybe it's pretty
and sounds nice.
That'll still sell.
ANDY FORSBERG: If that was
a pie and you had people
over for a party, would you
hand them only 2/3 of the pie?
They'd be like--
RICHARD LUDLOW: Crazy.
ANDY FORSBERG: --this
dude is selfish.
[LAUGHING]
RICHARD LUDLOW: He says that
because I eat like a pie--
I have a thing where
I eat a pie a week.
ANDY FORSBERG: That's
a whole other--
RICHARD LUDLOW:
But no, seriously,
so your game can function
without one of these things
being great.
But it's not going to be
as great of an experience.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 2: No?
Then I want to thank
you again very much
for speaking to our students.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Thank
you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, and feel free to put
up our email addresses.
Mine is rludlow his is aforsberg
if you want to-- Oh, OK.
ANDY FORSBERG: --@hexany--
oh, yeah, perfect.
OK, cool.
RICHARD LUDLOW: And yeah, feel
free to shoot us an email.
If you have any questions,
we're happy to support audio
with the new generation
of developers.
There's a lot of great
people over at Berkeley, too.
If you're looking for
composers and sound designers
to collaborate with,
other students,
there's a lot of great
people over there.
There's the Video
Game Music Club.
ANDY FORSBERG: Don't be
afraid to cross the bridge.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Yes.
The Video Game Music Club,
if you shoot them an email,
you'll get like 10
responses from people
who are like, yes, let me
help you work on this game.
You're not getting paid.
I'm not getting paid.
They might be OK with that.
ANDY FORSBERG: Yeah.
You guys have the
facilities for what you do.
And Berkeley has the
facilities for what they do.
RICHARD LUDLOW:
Anyway, but then you
can call us when
you've got paid gigs.
[TSKS]
ANDY FORSBERG:
(WHISPERING) Just saying.
RICHARD LUDLOW: All right.
Anyway, well, thanks so much.
I really appreciate you guys
caring about audio, really,
honestly.
We really appreciate
people caring about music
and sound a little bit.
So thanks so much.
ANDY FORSBERG: And good luck
with the rest of your semester.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Absolutely.
Thanks.
See you guys around.
ANDY FORSBERG: Cheers, guys.
RICHARD LUDLOW: Adios.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: All right.
So yeah, on that
note, if you are
taking CMS617 next semester, the
advanced game studio, CMS610,
the media arts industries
law class, both of those
are making a good
polished experience
for the end of the
semester, with the idea
of either showing
it to publishers
or submitting it to a festival.
So audio is really, really
important in those two classes.
And going to Berkeley
for that kind of support
is highly recommended.
Also recommend them
this class if you've
got the time, as well.
And let us know
if you'd like more
information about connecting
with Berkeley folks.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah, we
actually know the instructors
and even some alums.
But the alums know the people
who are still in college.
PROFESSOR 1: Yep, just
email Video Game Bosses
if you'd like that contact info.
Otherwise, you've got five
minutes to take a break,
meet back up with your teams.
And Pablo will be in at 2
o'clock to play three games.